are doctors contractors for the
hospitals are they like the calorie
employees it's both for example it's
very common that a hospital system would
contract an ER employer who then has a
bunch of ER doctors that work for them
so they don't even work for the hospital
they work for the ER employer and then
you have private practices like my dad
currently is a primary care doctor and
he has a private practice those are
getting bought off by Hospital systems
and they'll pay the provider a small
amount of money and then say okay we
essentially own all of your patients
there are members of our practice so
that if you refer patients it should be
within our system and now all of these
smaller doctors that used to run their
own sort of shops if you will are now
part of a great health system like a
bigger Health System